eine erkrankung die die nicht mehr
erlaubt zu sprechen was mutismus ist wie
sich diese äußert und was man dagegen
unternehmen kann das erfahrt ihr heute
bei klick zum science entwicklung wenn
man nicht sagt hat das nicht immer etwas
mit schüchternheit unlust oder
desinteresse zu tun
eine kaum bekannte erkrankung der
mutismus könnte der grund sein
fotos kommt aus dem lateinischen und
bedeutet sturm ihr kennt das von war
stärker gut das ist die stummschaltung
ein verstärker der buddhismus ist eine
kommunikationsstörung menschen die an
mutismus leiden verfallen entweder
situationsbedingt in schweigen oder
sprechen aus angst oder anderen gründen
einfach nicht sprechen könnten sie aber
es liegen nämlich keinerlei
dysfunktionen an den sprech organ oder
dem sprachzentrum vor bisher rätselt die
wissenschaft noch über die ursache der
erkrankung erste vermutung nach spielen
sowohl psychische und physische elemente
als auch das zusammenspiel beider eine
große rolle beispielsweise wird bei
betroffenen eine ungewöhnliche menge an
serotonin im gehirn gemessen eine
sogenannte über konzentration serotonin
ist ein neurotransmitter fehlt uns
dieser können wir angst schlechte laune
oder sogar depressionen entwickeln bei
mutismus ist es aber genau andersherum
traumata und missglückte lernprozesse im
entwicklungsstadium eines kindes
begünstigen die entwicklung der
erkrankung ebenso es gibt zwei arten des
buddhismus den totalen mutismus und den
selektivem mutismus wie der name schon
vermuten lässt bezieht sich der totale
mutismus auf nahezu alle aktivitäten im
leben und verschlägt betroffenen
durchgehend die sprache unter dem
selektivem mutismus versteht man dass
darunter leiden entweder nur mit
ausgewählten personen oder nur in
manchen situationen nicht sprechen
können
der selektive mutismus wird noch einmal
in vier weitere unterteil zwei davon
sind beispielsweise der sprecher erst
muss muss und der passiv aggressive
mutismus bei den sprech angst mutismus
verspüren die patienten eine enorme
angst beim hören der eigenen stimme
heftige stressreaktion des körpers sind
die folgen beim sprechen
der passiv aggressive mutismus äußert
sich dadurch dass betroffene schweigen
um abneigungen zu personen zu
kommunizieren ohne es direkt ansprechen
zu müssen eben passiv aber trotzdem
aggressiv sie vermeiden den aktiven
konflikt durch passives verhalten im
gegensatz zu der ursachenforschung ist
die forschung im bereich der passenden
therapien schon um einiges weiter
therapieverfahren wie die
verhaltenstherapie oder die
pharmakotherapie sind zwei von vielen
möglichen verfahren bei der
verhaltenstherapie wird mutismus als
erlernte strategie gesehen striktes
nichts sagen führt zu vermehrter
aufmerksamkeit diese aufmerksamkeit wird
von den betroffenen angenehm als
angenehm empfunden und mit dem verhalten
schweigen verknüpft also schweigen
gleich angenehm negatives verhalten wird
also durch positives erleben der
konsequenzen verstärkt in
therapiestunden wird den patienten das
schweigen mit hilfe von stimulus fading
und der positiven bewertung des
sprechens ab trainiert beim stimulus
fading wird der patienten nach und nach
also es wird ein gefährdet gezielt mit
personen und oder situationen
konfrontiert psychiater sprechen dann
von einer sogenannten exposition der
therapeut wissen sind die therapeutin
steht den betroffenen zur seite und
aufgabe des patienten ist dann zu
sprechen
diese exposition erwies sich in vielen
fällen als nützlich nachteil einer
verhaltenstherapie mit einer solchen
exposition sie ist sowohl körperlich als
auch psychisch sehr anstrengend für die
patienten
parallel zu einer verhaltenstherapie
wird gelegentlich auch eine
pharmakotherapie angewendet oft bei
mutismus auftretende angstzustände und
depressive verstimmungen werden somit
mit medikamenten abgeschwächt eine
medikamentöse behandlung ist nicht
unbedingt notwendig unterstützt die
verhaltenstherapie jedoch sehr gut ein
medikamenten wirkstoff der im fall von
mutismus häufig benutzt wird ist
fluoxetin ein amt antidepressiva in dem
hörbuch die erfindung des lebens
berichtet der autor hanns josef ortheil
von seinem leben als sohn einer frau die
durch mehrere traumatische erlebnisse
dem krieg und dem verlust ihrer vier
anderen söhne zu einer stummen mutter
wurde
das besondere bei diesem hörbuch ist die
authentizität des erzählers hanns-josef
ortheil selbst ließ seine geschichte
wenn euch das interessiert dann kommt
ihr hier oben zu unserem link zum buch
da könnt ihr auch dann einen probe
account erstellen und bekommt die
erfindung des lebens direkt kostenlos
als geschenk unseren link findet ihr
selbstverständlich auch in der video
beschreibung es lohnt sich wirklich wie
menschen und hunde ohne sprache
kommunizieren und warum das zwischen
menschen und wölfen nicht funktioniert
das erfahrt ihr in nicht sprechen zu
können kann ich mir persönlichen
überhaupt nicht vorstellen und ihr
könntet ihr bisher mutismus oder habt
ihr denn schon mal damit erfahrung
gemacht lasst es uns in den kommentaren
wissen und wie reagiert ihr wenn ihr
menschen begegnet die einfach nicht mit
euch sprechen wollen
also schreibt in die kommentare und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran